on the holiest night of ramadan more
violence on the streets of occupied east
jerusalem
palestinian protesters through water
bottles israeli security forces
used stun grenades foul-smelling
chemically laced water jets
and close up physical force
this man was beaten on the ground in
front of us
and then ushered away into the night
with no attempt to detain him
it wasn't an isolated incident
[Applause]
so the period just before and around
prayers was relatively calm here
in damascus gate but in the last few
minutes it's erupted
into another night of tension and
scuffles
the worry is that another potentially
violent night could ensue
in the following hours that potential
was fulfilled
the anger here isn't just about the
scenes from al-aqsa on friday when
stunned grenades were used inside the
mosque itself
it's been building over threats to
forcibly evict palestinian families
from their homes in the east jerusalem
neighborhood of shakespeare
people solidarity gave us the power to
continue with our peaceful resistance
all that we are asking is peaceful
solidarity against our eviction
we ask any organization or governments
to stand with us and help prevent the
forceful evictions in shaykh
we are the rightful owners we are the
owners of the land
all we want is for them to stay away the
forged papers they have do not make them
the rightful owners
it's been present since the start of the
holy month when pandemic weary people
found a major post-prayers gathering
point barred off and it's been
exacerbated by interventions from the
israeli far
right we don't have not
light at the end of the tunnel but we
don't have a tunnel because there is no
peace process
east jerusalem is occupied it's not
israeli sovereignty in jerusalem
it hasn't been recognized by the
international community
so we are sitting on
a volcano there are concerns of a
further deterioration
on monday thousands of jewish israelis
are set to march through the old city's
muslim quarter
to mark the israeli seizure of east
jerusalem in 1967
on the same day as a supreme court
hearing on the sheikh jura evictions
dangerous days ahead for a flashpoint
city
there can be both a focal point and a
fuse for conflict within
and far beyond its streets harry fawcett
al-jazeera
occupied east jerusalem
general of the palestinian national
initiative political party
he says this is the latest example of
years of oppression
what you see here is a reflection of a
system of racism
and discrimination against palestinians
not only we have been under occupation
for more than 54 years
but on top of that israel has
established a system of apartheid and
racial discrimination
the vast majority of palestinians today
are prohibited from reaching jerusalem
and participating in
prayer in the mosque as much as the
christians were also prohibited from
participating in the eastern
during easter time to be in the church
of holy sepulchre this is a
discriminatory system
and of course what you see here is
protest against this
discrimination on top of that israel as
you have
indicated is trying to conduct ethnic
cleansing
in one of the major neighborhoods in
as much as they do that also in other
neighborhoods in jerusalem so basically
this is the evolution of a strong
struggle
against racism against apartheid and
against the occupation that has lasted
longer than anybody
can tolerate